First question we sort to have to
ask ourselves is how do we know
that a certain system that
claims to be a TCB or
Trusted Computing Base is actually,
can actually be trusted?
So trusted is actually not
the only set of qualified we use.
We call systems secure systems, trusted,
I've been using this word, but
also high assurance systems.
So, security you can think of this
as a binary property in some sense,
either something is secure,
or it's not secure and
something can go wrong and
while the security requirement.
Trusted is typically sort of higher
level of confidence that you
have that it's going to do the right
thing, what it is expected to do,
this level of trustworthiness, trusted
our reliance on it and things like that.
High assurance, basically,
is a similar sort of idea.
It does what it's supposed to do
with a very high level of assurance.
I should say that the hardware that we
have, you need some place to stand on.
Hardware is obviously something
that we're going to trust, and
software that has direct
access to the hardware,
which makes up your operating system,
the trusted computing base.
We have to trust it and anything else
that will be able to make claims about
the level of trust that we have in the
system is going to depend on the trust
that we have in this underlying
trusted computing base.
So enforcement of a security policy
because we implement access control in
a certain way, or
isolation of processes,
isolation of untrusted
code from trusted code.
All that is going to rely on this
level of trust that we have or
the level of assurance that we have,
that the trusted computing base would do
what it supposed to do, and
nothing more and nothing less.